[Music]
hello
hello
hello
i think we're live
i
think can ever tell with youtube
shot
i haven't streamed in a minute
one sec
one second
i gotta make sure everything
is perfect
and
we're gonna share it we're gonna do that
okay we are live sick
what up what up what up what up what up
what up
what up spacey
how are we doing
happy
what day is it today
tuesday
oh i gotta make sure i close my window
so i don't uh upset people with my
random loud talking
if they're going on a nice walk
[Music]
okay
and do a little bit of that
i'm gonna do that
we're gonna send that out
man we have lost a lot of people in the
discord and i'm actually okay with that
okay hold on
hold up
we mean finally kyle
immediately pisses me off
i'm just kidding i love you too kyle how
are you
how's your day been pretty good solid
day
i'm going to die to melania like 75
times right now but it's a good day
i gotta be melania the dragonlord and
moog
and then finish the game
this hoe
i hate that attack
i always get hit by it
[Music]
that was scary
i don't think i hit her
stop
oh god
she could definitely waterfowl
very soon
oh my god
i'm bad
i tried to stop and roll
i should have rolled
your radon video has influenced my
thoughts so much and i now worship his
horse
nice
i'm glad you liked it
you know how it has been working
constantly it's a vibe dude what
happened
i feel like everyone got so busy
in the last like month
i trey
oh god
wow
nuts
nuts
crazy with it
god
i gotta get in the flow i gotta get in
the move set
oh that's bad
i didn't get hit by it
i got hit by it
okay why is she so aggressive randomly
she just did the same move three times
i always blame it on the weather
i feel like the weather has nothing to
do with your work
miss
what were you trying to hunt
lore
in general
i want to look more at this boss room
but i have to you know get her out of
the way first
holy she's aggressive right now
oh i could dodge in you see that
i'm almost dead
oh god
bonk
hmm
i don't think a summon is gonna be very
good in this fight i knew it
i'm bad
jesus
need to find more tiers
i have seven
that's a lot it's a good amount
i just need to like not get hit
that's the issue here
i'm glad you like the postman
thank you dude
nah using a summon she heals from a
summon
[Music]
she does a lot of damage holy [ __ ]
yeah i have a jelly summon
plus five gets finesse super fast she
heals from it too
not worth
i bet a mimic would be worth it probably
yeah she gets healed from hitting you
and the summit yaya
so glad you gave to youtube me too trey
it has been a very nice experience
i see you're dealing with some [ __ ]
yeah
you know
hey we're all dealing with the same
[ __ ] though so
even playing field
okay she does not get uh
i i really don't understand that attack
she doesn't get staggered from my first
big hit
right here she will
weird know what i need is a perry shield
i could change this up
i think i would rather deal with
waterfowl than that attack it's crazy
weak to ice dude everything's weak to
ice
this is op
that right there i don't get it
that's not good waterfell
coming in
did they fix her right there
because she used to just like fly up in
the air randomly
there's also a patch today
that fixed a lot of stuff
you want a waterfowl i know it you're
gonna
you're gonna do it come on
come on
come on
um
i'm gonna get close and she's gonna do
it watch
i thought i had no healing i i pretty
much don't
i'm just scared of this one mechanic
i'm like
over
level 100
there it is
[Music]
oh
ow
oh let's go devildog
oh that's brandon hi brandon
it was great seeing you too
yeah dual swords are fun
but yeah i'm level uh
111 dude
it's pretty high
we do a lot of damage but we die pretty
quick
which happens
man can stunner if you equip the right
spells yep
i don't have the mimic though we could
go get the mimic
that sounds like a lot of work
i'm just gonna get good
why do i continue to do the heavy attack
off the rip when it doesn't work
the world may never know
dude
calm yourself
chicken waterfowl here
definitely can
i heard from someone that you can um
stun her out of it
out of the waterfowl what can i use to
do that
because now i'm just baiting her like
she
she's gonna do it
when i get too damn close
it's common
have fun at the hockey game glenn
good to see you
is it storm stop
i don't know
oh the flies that's too slow don't you
think
why is she not doing it i'm confused
okay here it comes yep there it is
still almost died because i don't
understand
wouldn't it do it
i was still like a little bit too close
i guess
i'm just popping this
i need a shield
oh but we gotta get lucky with blood
loss though huh
i feel like i should get a parry sword
[ __ ]
uh that's why i don't like this fight
dude i just care about one attack
ancient death rancor i've never heard of
that
stags are most of the time if it one
hits her you can also spam it
do i have a shield that can parry
blasphemous blade
technically this parries
little dinky thing
this may not even work
it's like not strong enough for
something i have no idea
okay not doing the strong attack off the
rope
tried to parry there
i could be here all day
trying to learn the parries on this
also the only people like the only
shield i've seen
people use for parries
is uh
the buckler perry shield
this is just a little wooden dinky thing
well you gotta bury your three times to
get a stagger
got scared
one
i don't think it's a good idea either
but it's fun
[Music]
i'm learning it's not worth it
two
okay it works at least
three okay
good work
one
and then the entire fight's ruined by
one attack dude
i had a lot of people saying that um
they didn't think the waterfowl dance
was [ __ ] but i really do think it is
i parried her four times so that wasn't
bad
that one attack is why she's a b tier to
me
it ruins the fight in my opinion
otherwise it's a beautiful dance
[Music]
that was [ __ ] brave
no idea why i did that
too late
she's gonna do it soon
nice
[Music]
actually don't know how i missed that
okay
thank you alec
sometimes it's a question of does she
just decide she wants to win or not it
really is
i i know
the the finesse
is very good
i should parry
and then like switch back and forth
to using bloodhounds finesse
and pairing
no i don't call that cheating you can
use in summon if you want to i just
don't want to
i want to do it
like this
i think it's possible
[Music]
i'm learning that dodging in
works quite often with her
like very often
[ __ ]
dang it
man dude i messed up one time
otherwise i was going really well
no i don't want to do that kyle
it's a good talisman though
i just gotta get good dude
and i'm not good yet
um
all right
sometimes that weird
one two three attack she does just i get
caught up in it
and i get a little bit staggered
and then it just ends my life
man
this fight is so hard dude
bearing is fun though
too early i think
way too early
i get nervous
okay somewhere in between there and
we're
looking good
have no idea how that hit me
what the heck was that
not good
so far
i could get two hits there
i just straight up
didn't think she'd do that
terrible
uh
i panicked i just started rolling
everywhere dude
because she was this
bopping around
eventually she'll give you the dub
i don't know about that
i'm starting to think parrying is in uh
isn't our play
i'm gonna do it anyway
no i am not in the market at all for an
editor sorry to say
i wish i could afford an editor
it's nice of you
don't
not really making that kind of money yet
one
rp walked order
anime
anime
oh here it comes
i appreciate that man i yeah i just
can't afford one right now
two right yes
right stagger here soon
no i dodged
i promise as bad as this is looking
right now
we are we are getting better
it depends on if she identifies as an
attack helicopter
true
i'm trying to afford groceries right now
so
i gotta edit my own stuff
nope
nope
nope
nope
do you have moog's little roon farm open
on this character
um i don't farm runes i beat bosses and
use their runes
i don't like farming
it's boring
and dumb
but people can do it if they want
i just don't wanna
ow
oh my god
trust me i would love
love
to have an editor
just can't afform it
afford it
have a good day brandon
nah this chicks easy
just kidding she's not
one
[Music]
dang
it's coming
okay
now
it was all going well
it was going great and then she's like
whoop let me just end this fight real
quick is what she said
gosh
i'm telling you guys
people who defend that attack i don't
understand it is it ruins the fight it
really really does
is it possible to inflict rod on her i
doubt it
because she is the rot queen
or the goddess of rot
i would imagine
that rob doesn't work on her but i don't
know that for sure
i did try to parry the helicopter
it did not work
it did not
go well
and then i just blocked
and that didn't go well either
is this in a cave over there
oh
but yeah i will not
farm runes i don't like it
easy to dodge
tell us how how it's easy to dodge when
she can just bring it up out of nowhere
dude
please let me know how it's an easy
dodge
is people who say that i'm pretty sure
it is shooting [ __ ]
like where
it's easy to dodge if you're
far enough away
if you're too close you're dead
i messed up
i messed up
i'm just trying to look cool
it's coming
i
gotcha can i tell you how i beat her i
mean i've beaten her five times
so i know how to beat her
technically six times
it's still hard there it is
i didn't realize how close we were to
the wall okay
[Music]
um
what
that that hit me
yep swarm of flies
that's what kyle said earlier
hey
i
i feel it in her
i can feel her getting mad that i'm
trolling her
and she's just gonna pop it
pop it
okay wait
there it is
we're dead
okay that was our best run so far
i died
i need an ash of war let me solo her ash
aboard
exactly
beaten her 40 times now helping her out
or helping people out kyle nice
nice
i did hear there is
quite a bit of input reading in this
game where like
the ai will sense like when you heal or
use like my bloodhound's finesse
and it'll just like do the thing
that you really don't want it to do
in that moment
whoops
have you asked nice
have you nicely asked her to calm down
um
no how many times you've beaten her
tactic uh six
one time a new game plus
that was actually the first time i ever
found her was a new game plus one
and then i've this is my
sixth account
so i guess five times
but none with this kind of build this
build's kind of hard
it's like a strength deck spilled
out
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
two grabs
huh the heck
you are
being
mean
you know what chat let's see how jelly
does
be free jelly
destroy
get it
yeah jelly
now re-aggro
dinner
you got it jelly
oh she has eyes on the back of her head
does not stagger on that one does not
stagger on that one got it
kill jelly
what
no
this is not the way to do
this well
now she has all her health back
i thought i had my shield out
have a good day trey
have a good day giz
yeah i'm still trying to uh figure out
what video i want to do next
i want to do one on melania and mikola
i'm so nervous to face here i got to the
mountains and i'm level 130. i mean i'm
at her at
111
and it's really hard so
you'll be fine
[Music]
do i have my shield out i do it's hidden
one
that reached oh my god
five hp that's rough bro
lauren mickela specifically sick dude
sick
holding off on new game plus still dlc
drops but on a third run now
yeah i'm like on new game plus
six on my main account
now i just like making new builds
i tried to parry while i was stuck
still falling and [ __ ] um
or rolling
dude sometimes she just comes out
[ __ ] hot man like crazy
[Music]
can i parry that
okay
between the rot and some other god
i thought i read somewhere that there
was like a rot god
to my knowledge
she was just born with a
a defect
because
her parents are the same person
which usually leads to some [ __ ] up
business
but i think there's definitely more to
it i thought i've read something about a
rot god i just haven't seen it myself
she's the rock god now
the goddess of rot
there we go i think we need to be more
aggressive with her
i like this plan
nevermind well i still do
ah that makes sense that she's a
yeah
interesting
i'm definitely gonna look into it
dude
where is
my parry
where is my perry
we got a lot of lag going on there what
the hell
blame it on the lag
the lag i lagged
yeah she's definitely not the rock god
i feel like she got [ __ ] over
which is the vibe i get with a lot of
demigods in this game
one
dude i did not think she'd swing there
[Music]
[Music]
my headphones
they're bugging out
my headphones are bugging
two
and i'm dead
i hate that attack man i think it's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
nicola is actually holding every outer
god back from the lands between
yeah see this is why i need to look into
mykola
i think i want to point out is um
maybe this is common knowledge i have no
idea but
look at
the boss room in here
so that's
at least a husk of nicola right there
right do you see that like big
hole
like where a ball would go
like right in the middle is that where
that ball that in uh the mogwin palace
is that where it came from
why are my headphones [ __ ] dude
one
yes cool
that's what i thought
looks like relatively the same size
almost did something there god damn
i love how that guy in chat who said
like dude dodging that attack is easy
it just didn't say anything else
just like gone
lucas thank you
i don't know what's going on with my
headphones i'll only hear like the
swings halfway through it's weird
i really need to get new ones
so it is the same ball
radagon america i think we're always the
same person that's why the turtle speaks
about the artist saw and ratagon secret
i think they were too
i think america like created
ratagon technically
he grabbed a big spoon and scooped
michael out
with his like forks beer he stuck it
like a meatball
we gotta go fight him too
i'm
dead oh this is a spoiler room
absolutely
spoil it up boys i've beaten this game
so many times
i'm trying to learn as much as i can
and i think in a lore hunting
stream
totally fine to spoil spoil it up
if you don't want to get spoiled you
probably shouldn't be here
give me theories give me everything
shouldn't have done that
was an interesting combo
dude what
ow
rumor has it mikala and saint trina are
the same thing
well yeah just knowing that it's
possible for that to be a thing who
knows how many people are the same
person right
i still think melano and ronnie are the
same person
beep i got [ __ ]
how's your stream going by the way
that game looks so cute the one you're
playing i forget what it's called but
the one with the little
fox all right melania
blade of nothing
haha
two
[Music]
i was too far away and i'm dead
it
it's crazy how fast this fight switches
up
it's cute dark souls that's what i
thought
to dodge it you have to dodge into the
first roll away from the second and into
the third she will split sprint to the
other side of arena and needs practice
i'm gonna try that
into the first in out in
in out in all right
there's a theory that ratagon is the
second half of america she was cursed by
the fire giants turn gold hair to red
and split herself because of it i'm
pretty sure um like that's confirmed
everything lore wise in this game chat
is speculative so like anything you guys
say could be true like uh this candle
right here guys that is the outer god
right there because the fire was made by
the greater will like you know that
could technically be true
wow
off to a hot start
still trying to learn when she staggers
interesting
that was a brave perry because i was
dead if i didn't hit it
i am the outer god
that sent the elden beast
it's me
or it's beep
you know what chat
the outer gods are all dogs
hey
i already done
whoops
uh alchemy seems to be an honest
connection to the elden ring
and if it's true then we are looking for
multiple creations of the magnus opus
meaning the philosopher's stone taking
the form of man and woman
my head hurts
my head hurts
i hurt my head
it was a huge finding for me when i
found out that the elden beast is a
vassal instead of a vessel
yeah he was sent by the greater will
he's just like
part of it
i think of the greater will like a
universe right
and we're just one little thing
what if they're birds
then they go
you know what they are they're those
those birds with the talons dude i swear
rp walk
badass walk toward each other
[Music]
yo
i'm gonna get so good at this fight that
i can just do that stuff
do whatever i want
it's not going to be right now that i'm
like that it's going to take some work
but we can get it done
yeah they're probably one of the dino
dogs
dude the dino dogs
i don't know about y'all but i have had
some nightmares about those dino dogs
man
they are scary
watch
i'm gonna pop off at some at some point
here and we're just gonna like
not even take damage it's gonna be crazy
you'll be like what
oh my god
i'm so tired please work rest of day for
me no
i'm working right now
can even tag people on youtube chat i
have no idea
i haven't streamed enough
i'm dead
so is that mickel are right there chat
or it's just like kind of a husk
it's got to be a host because we know
like the body of nicholas with moog but
maybe that's not mikala like
chat do we truly know anything
no we don't
yep i'll get in the flow and we'll be
good
yeah i just started streaming on youtube
solid so like we don't know anything
looks like a sculpture
it does
it like there's a face up there if you
look close enough
my game lag there's a face in there man
but
again could just be a husk
lag
okay we're fine guys i'm gonna switch
from the parry and go back to finesse
not a good start with that
we're gonna bleed her up
i should heal
and i will
melania's got some thick thighs
i dodged in
how is moog planning to have children
um
with an egg
could be the huss was meant for nicholas
full body but mo just yoinked it
so does does melania just not know
that mickel is not there
i'm going back to the parry
we are figuring this out i promise this
is going better than it than it seems
i'm coming to the conclusion that i'm
doing this very under level
night beep
[Music]
where is my parry
i don't think i was facing the right
direction
oh
i swear to god she just
yoinks it out of nowhere and just you're
dead
also i have not seen a single person do
the dodging that
i think gilgamesh said in chat earlier
where it's in out in
i have quite literally never seen that
she does i mean she it seems like she's
waiting there
i don't think melania can see chat
i mean
it seems like she can see
but maybe her hearing's like so good
because her eyes are rotted over
that's why she wildly just flails around
because she doesn't really know where we
are
it could be
uh
isn't mikala a male
i think so
maybe not
i don't think gender matters much in
this world
um
carried by a lone rot soldier after the
fight with radon
and as far as we know she bloomed
outside the arena and slept here since
yeah
i think so too
what soldier just put her in that chair
what a legend
the body in the egg at mo's place
doesn't seem like someone who's cursed
with being a child well i mean yeah
they're large but think of demi-gods you
know like they're
some of them are big
i don't know
leonard thank you
you guys like my spongebob alerts
i'm a big fan of spongebob
one
there's some
do your dumb thing
here comes i'm too close
run
help
help
oh come on
i know it's i mean yep
jesus oh she ran into the wall that's
why she went back got it
i don't trust you
for very obvious reasons
there it is
how did that hit me
no
[Music]
there's the bleed
holy [ __ ]
it keeps running her into the wall
yeah i'm the best
i'm the best there ever was
the best you've all ever seen
wasn't even hard
i think mickela grew inside the cocoon
it well if that's true then he's done so
much inside the cocoon like
he's he you guys know he gave a ratagon
his own sword
like a great sword
and then
you know he wanted godwin wrote a
message the god win i forget what item
it was
wait the
something or other
he's done a lot
and again i think it's a guy
i should summon let me solo her
that'd be awesome
but i want to do it myself i want to get
better at this fight too
[Music]
you guys see her eyes like i don't think
she can see anything i truly do
i think she's blind
it would explain kind of her frantic
swiping of the sword
yeah no shot she can see
[Music]
god that is badass
i have no idea how i got hit by that
i thought i rolled
audibly screaming no
on phrase too
uh
i saw it coming i think the first time i
played through i was like yeah there's
no way that's it
what do do we know why she says you will
witness true horror
like i i know she's just like trying to
intimidate us but that feels like a very
interesting statement to make right
what does she mean by that
do we know like if the rot like induces
nightmares or something
you could grab the black knife armor set
from underneath the teleporter that
takes you to a hollow tree
black knife armor set
i don't know i look pretty sick dude
i'm so i'm so fashion souls dude like i
don't i don't care about how effective
items are i just want to look cool
makes your movements completely silent
maybe
mistranslation i don't think it's a
mistranslation
but because it's a sick thing to say you
will witness true horror
that's badass
all right we got good one time let's do
it again
one
two
i tried there my headphones are also
messing up again
i'm like a hundred percent certain
that's only on my end though so yeah
okay
that would be interesting kyle
but uh i doubt it
she went from her goddess form
so to us
mortal probably would fear it
or it's a big f
or it's a big f you to people who took
nine hours to beat her
witnessing true horror yeah
i don't know
i wasn't the only one who thought this
boss is impossible at first
just to find out there's another phase
um
i never thought this boss was impossible
i just thought one move was stupid
and i still do
i'm sorry but the that was just a
terrible attempt
the the waterfowl is just
i don't like it
silly
i don't know how they would fix it
though how do you guys think they could
fix waterfowl or do you think they just
shouldn't mess with it at all
i found eachine
and orphan of course to be way easier
than melania
to be fair i feel like i was really good
at securo though
i don't feel like i'm really anything
good at this game
i just like kind of know what i'm doing
so i can get through it you know
eventually
[Music]
sekiro's combat will always be the best
i don't think they need to remove
waterfowl
i don't
the way it is right now i think is dumb
and i'm taking these really brave
berries huh
oh my god
[ __ ] off just for a second
thank you
find radon to be extremely easy
before after and then another every
patch i've found him easy
i uh yeah and
what's crazy is a lot of this is just
preference to the player
like there are there's people who are
better at finding melania than others
you know and then
people really struggle with radon and
others don't
just gonna whip that out right there huh
i don't know i quite like the version of
the fight we got
i i like the fight 90
95 of the fight is is perfect in my
opinion though everything other than the
waterfowl about this fight is perfect
i think i think the waterfowl is stupid
sister frida
sister sister frida's nuts
but i think melania's harder
you can cheese freda
take the heel there
nice
oh i see why my parry's not going off
there now it's because i'm facing the
other way
i i very well may have had one health
there
tried to parry an attack i wasn't used
to
it's got to be coming right
there it is
wasn't quite facing here
oh it's dodgeable
only if you're a certain distance away
though which is the stupid part to me
if you're too close you die
oh she's gonna do it
terrible attempt
let's just keep going
[Music]
[Music]
that scared me
come on
i know she's gonna do it
okay i guess that hit me
radon was easily one of the hardest
souls bosses for me until melania took
around 60 attempts see i i beat radon in
three tries first time through
i i died once to his normal attacks
i well actually i think i died it was
arrows like five times but like the
normal fight where you actually like get
up to him i think i only died like three
times i did not find radon hard at all
if you're close to her when she does it
you need to walk circles under her
and land behind her as she does the
first dash of the combo
what do you mean walk circles like this
but kyle didn't you die like 50 times to
the pumpkin head
oh my god dude if you get caught in that
you're [ __ ] dead too like
i i don't know man i think this bite
this fight is beautiful but man
i don't know
i don't know
is she easier for casters um i mean i
watched one playthrough of a
intelligence build like
and that guy was stuck here for like
five hours straight
so i don't think so
it's very hard to do but it's a way to
survive the combo hitless all right
i thought i could get another swing off
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
comics not even good anymore
well it is
god damn it
[Music]
oh but i imagine using the the comet
when she goes into phase two
where she's just sitting there forever
yeah that's probably a lot easier there
i'd use a bow and torrent to kill radon
that's what i mean to some people
struggle and others don't
i like that
i think it's cool
how how the [ __ ] do you walk
circles around here that makes no
sense there's like no time to do that
there
i think i think a way that they could
fix her waterfowl is if there's a
if there's a tell to it you know
because she just pops it out of nowhere
dude
like maybe if she like adjusted her
sword really quick or something and then
jumped up into the air i don't know
there's just no tell like she just does
it whenever she wants at a certain part
of her health bar
that's the only thing i don't like about
it i like the attack
i think the attack is awesome but it's
just so
it's the only thing i think about in the
fight
and that sucks
[Music]
i mean i've seen the clip
i i don't think it's a consistent way
to do that
i mean i watched lobos jr just keep his
distance at certain points
and very mostly
my headphones are really bugging me
come on
what the
holy game lag
just caught me
why does he have to give your name and
job description every time you die
she's gotta let you know man
what's up molimer
yep
i godskin duo is way [ __ ] easier than
this fight
gods can do is nothing to this
man
ow
i think we're just gonna be here all day
like okay okay okay i'm gonna let you
guys choose because i will keep fighting
her i i like doing all of the fights in
this game
as much as it takes to do it but do we
do do we do we go to moog
we go do uh dragon lord or should i just
keep doing this i don't care while you
figure that out i'm gonna go do it one
more time
it's just a bad fight totally agree
totally agree they could have done it
better
they also should have made a different
version of the
godskin characters
like maybe they come out in
black robes or they're a little bit
bigger
i don't know because we see them so much
in this damn game
i'm dead
yeah the godskin i think was just like a
i think it was a lore spot actually
like a lore fight
i i don't know why they had us fight him
so many times i'm gonna go do it one
more time because that was just a bad
attempt
of the elden ring ornstein and smoke
yeah but ornstein and smoke was really
cool
like i love that fight the godskin fight
i don't like it all
because it was fair one was fat and was
slow and the other one was fast and
nimble
in this game the fat one is faster than
the skinny one
i am melania
blade of mikkela
i'm dead
i am melania
blade of michaela
and i'm going to kill you
oh
yep they can fix that fight just by
speak i think they can respond
here here's how you fix the god skin to
a fight
they can still respawn but if you kill
the other one before he respawns the
other one then the fight's over does
that make sense
that would completely fix the fight in
my opinion
so
[Music]
okay she's gonna do it
she didn't do it doing this
[Music]
hey
i'm dead
i would have been very upset if i died
there
game
game
i'm dead
it's like i'm fighting a tree sentinel
again
oh that is so freaking sad dude my focus
got messed up
from the lag
nice told you dude that is not what you
said because i was already running away
from it i totally get that you can dodge
in on like the second time she does the
whole thing or whatever
that i get that
but the fact is if you are too close you
die
95 percent of the time
so
i it's still [ __ ]
she now farts
surprise that doesn't stagger
now i'm obscenity spaghetti
that that attack is some [ __ ] too
he's gotta dodge in
i messed up
maybe a lore video about the frenzy
flame or lance between timeline video
would be cool
oh lance between between timeline video
is a great idea
i really like that idea good one good
one good one
frenzied flame i think
yeah definitely will make that one
video game there we go
uh
or actually something practical and cool
hi cole
how are you
stop
my headphones are messing up
goodness
i didn't think she'd go for the backhand
[Music]
oh we gotta go at it once more cole
rp walk right toward her
perry
a [ __ ] backhand man
i'm dead
i'm no longer alive
i'm dead
do it i know you want to
why did my characters stop running
that's annoying
why didn't i parry her
okay
do we watch the cut scene again
yes it's been so long i need a
i need a [ __ ] second man
that was a good that was a decent run
though
like that didn't feel terrible
oh and i love our jobs you guys have
been working a lot man
a lot a lot i also don't do as much like
interactable content as i used to so
you know
like i don't stream as much
and then we live very far apart which
makes me sad i was telling maddie the
other day cole that we need to like move
in together
closer to each other i'm moving to
minnesota wait
wait
i am not done
you will
witness true horror
hey i got a call
from someone i don't know
[Music]
me too solid
[Music]
oh we definitely are kyle we're figuring
it out
we can do it like this
last time i got here i died immediately
god that is so cool
do you want to move the texas coal
anywhere but texas
i hear everyone's moving to texas which
makes me not want to move to texas
what is my deal with this
i've i'd never get hit by this thing
that's happened twice now
man
uh
i need to run under her
damn it
the goddess of salt
just keep rolling
rolling rolling
i have to pee but i won't
i'll pee my pants
yep i need to run underneath her i know
i panicked okay
i didn't want to admit it but i panicked
stop it
sorry if that scared you
i needed to audibly
let you know
how i felt about that
ow
i'm not alive
bad healing bad run
weed
you [ __ ]
[Music]
i don't know
how i'ma leave
i don't think she heals from parries i
don't know
i have not paid attention
i'm not alive
good night solid
i don't know how people have level won
this chick oh it's it's possible
it's possible
absolutely
you just gotta get good dude like they
just don't get hit
i get hit a lot
the thing is we're getting better and
better with every attempt chat we really
are
thank you todd
whether or not they like the soundtrack
is my new
litmus test for strangers
all right
the music in this fight is awesome
yep
agreed
[Music]
yes i did kyle
i think i've been hit once and now i'm
dead
isn't that crazy how that just flipped
the script right there because i
didn't realize how low her health was
and that she could do that
melania would be a perfect
sakiro boss oh yeah with deflecting
that'd be awesome i wish they kind of
like
i wish they put a katana in this game
that can do like
actual sakiro deflections that would be
great
i was reading chat
it's all your fault i'm just kidding
that'd be an awesome mod
put melania and sakiro that would be
sick someone make that now like right
now now do it now right now
now
do it now
i died
and we've been at this for an hour and a
half huh
all right game lagged
lag
it's the only reason you hit me [ __ ]
that's right i called you that
don't deny you've called her that too
many times
am i crouching
okay
i was too late
i'm too close
it's fine
do i have a lawyer thing that i want to
talk to you guys about
after i die right now so
if you were wondering what her name was
and her title
there you go
do you guys think that the lands between
is a dream
the whole thing
i think everything's a dream it's not
even real
none of it's real
the whole thing
milberg
oh man
it's an easy fight you just learn every
single thing she can do dodge everything
flawlessly and then punish accordingly
no problem i i mean that's exactly right
dude and i just haven't done that yet
i will keep the grind
strong
valentines
very brave perry with
quite possibly
no health
how do i see my health
i don't know
i don't see it
[Music]
i think it's a pain in world 2
from dark souls 3.
you're bad
i died
oh you think it's boring
i think it being a painted world is more
interesting than it being a dream
there's just so many aspects of the game
that make me think that though
like obviously it's a fantasy world but
it also just everything about it just
gives me like uh
dream
vibes you know
sorry my headsets
messing up
do we know where all those paintings
come from in the game
i deserve to die
she's doing moves that i don't like
i like that move
knew that was coming soon
you think this is a prequel
hmm
it's potential
i'm crouching
do the waterfowl
thank you
owned
earbuds
i didn't mean it
i knew it
yay
hey
[Music]
she delays that
i died
it
i didn't die to the beginning thing this
time but now i need to learn the second
moveset again
with the stuff about frenzy and outer
gods it's such a bloodborne connection
and you guys really think so huh
i
can't can't discredit it completely
i i don't think so
i
i think it's the same concept as a
painted world
does it necessarily mean it's from the
dark souls series like the exact same
no
has something to do with trees
definitely has stuff to do with trees
dang it
okay i'm not gonna heal
i should have healed
was there a group of knights in ariandel
i don't remember them worshiping a tree
i don't
i do not recall
okay i'm gonna try one more good attempt
and then we're gonna go and do dragon
lord
i should have healed maddie i should
have healed
back up [ __ ]
james lagging
couldn't handle the p
the walk
too cool
wow i hate it when my game completely
stops working
that was terrible
okay
there it is
oh yeah go ahead
that that timing of her doing that
specific attack
was really really awful
that was some input [ __ ] like the game
registered that i was healing and it's
like
do that one attack that's really fast
and covers the entire distance of the
boss room
and then she did it
the trees are getting bigger
nope one more good attempt that wasn't
good enough
better
back up [ __ ]
uh-huh
smell it
do it
and
we're getting better
run
help
help
yeah mug's a fun fight hard as [ __ ] too
all right sick
stop
thank you
i dumbed her
oh
[Music]
nice
[Music]
thank god you can still perry in this
[Music]
police
stop
she did that so much slower before
and then she did it fast
hey we're making progress though huh
well now i got to do it
again that's how this works man i felt
good so we're close
she wrecked my booty though
maddie uh maddie got it right
god the music in her second phase is so
freaking awesome
um
well
let me go go again
i just like this fire
i'm moving it to an a on my tier list
just because most of it's fun
it it did however sit in the b slot
i i like
yep
i like turtles
pop in this bad boy
kind of a waste
you like that move right now don't you
a little hoe
rp
walk do it
you're bad
wait
i missed it two times
two times
are we regressing
regressing
potentially
all right while you guys figure out the
next boss
i'm gonna go do it again
all right moog or dragon lord pick one
or pick melania
okay
we're going to the dragon lord
jesus this fight is hard
my ego is been destroyed
can't you fight morgot or did you kill
him already oh yeah we killed morgot we
pretty much done everything
except like uh all that stuff
we just uh if we kill
like we could go to the throne
because i think it's
yup capital of ash
where is the dragon lord fair missoula
beside the great bridge please
thank you
you haven't seen it much
i think the dragonlord might be my
favorite fight
and my favorite soundtrack
in fact it is my favorite soundtrack i'm
going the wrong way
it reminds me of little nightmares too
oh yeah we killed reichardt a long time
ago we have uh four great runes
four
sorry i'm still fixing my headset
it's gonna be my next thing i get i need
a new headset it doesn't work
we can go kill him together
okay i forget where this is sometimes
don't i get something from melania to
like stop the flame of frenzy
as well
let's think chat we gotta run this whole
way every time we die to this guy
yeah madeir will always be my favorite
dragon boss
the dragonlord's really well done too
the dragon lord is [ __ ] sick
i forgot i had to pee
the needle
okay i think i have the needle
i have a needle
a golden needle
just don't die
that's solid [ __ ] advice
i'll take that
thank you
you get
two
okay i have not given it to bach yet
imagine the dlc dragon it's probably a
guarantee we're gonna get one
i don't know what they're gonna do for
dlc they can get so [ __ ] creative
with it dude
i'm excited
and now that this game is like
mainstream maybe they'll like kick it
into gear and like do it fast who knows
and give us like lots of dlc
because there are a lot of great rune
slots that are sitting empty
really maddie
really
are you for real
sick
i'll keep that in mind
i think this is my favorite boss room
damn
who are these guys
you guys are just giving the best advice
i've heard in my life
that comes in fast
ah
[Music]
fire
ow
fire hot
owie
imagine getting hit by that dinky ass
tail dude
i did
this is bad bad bad bad run run
that is sick
um
okay so his neck fat killed me i guess
i didn't even see him move that was
weird
so laura behind fair missoula why what
happened to this place i don't know yet
i have not looked into pharaoh missoula
yet
went the wrong way
i'm staring into your [ __ ] soul
nah this boss is sick
he's hard but he's not like millennia
hard
the run too it's kind of annoying
i guess this is me dying to every
secret boss in the game this stream
god damn this run
we go again
yeah
every fight has some issue some issues
i don't think you can make a perfect
fight
it's not possible
i think that reaches too far back bro
[Music]
i do love gail
why do i feel like i'm doing no damage
457 huh
god damn that that looked awesome holy
[ __ ]
what
[Music]
so
how is that hitting me
okay
i don't understand
it is what it is
you just burn your own tail dawg
i'm not alive
damn that fire is crazy
almost got him though
tail weapons
what are tail weapons
is that a thing or i might be tripping i
just don't remember
hello
boom
uh-oh
we're fine
cut off boss's tail to get a weapon
i don't think so
not that i've seen
not a lot of tails
besides the dragons
i mean like the gargoyles from dark
souls
i don't think so
oh and cease
i keep forgetting i have to pee dude
right
i mean none that we know of
maybe i have to hit this boss's tail
with a particular weapon
howie
we just don't know it yet
fire
i make this guy bleed
i can make him stagger
nerd
1400 damage though like come on bro
oh man
what
what's that
oh
that is quite literally the coolest
attack i've ever seen
that might be the coolest attack ever
no cap
i don't know how to dodge that
apparently
[ __ ] delay dude and then just insta
fire
what
all right
this ain't going well right now
is he tired
what
oh god here we go
yep
so
you cannot
run away from that
got it
man bro
i'm getting my [ __ ] kicked in today
telling you strength dex builds
it's the hardest way to play this game
man
it's got some good weapons
but
man
all right we're going to get him this
try though 100
and when i do kill him i might remember
to go pee in fact i'm gonna get down
here i'm gonna play the yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay i'm gonna go pee i'll be right back
talk smack about me
there's nothing to talk smack about
i'm perfect in every conceivable way
just like you
now you don't know how to feel
i've confused you
okay
why
why
why
am i just getting annihilated now dude
oh you know what's crazy and let me know
if you guys have a very similar
experience to me
i find the
end game
to be
vastly
more difficult
than 80 percent of the game
like it doesn't
it really doesn't
uh filter its way about like in a
balanced way
to the end game it is just
it goes from like okay yeah this is this
is pretty good pretty easy to just like
yeah if you [ __ ] up you're dead
you got a plus 10 weapon and 40 bigger
imagine
you're dead
you're dead bucco
all right
try hard pants are on
and little did you know i wasn't wearing
pants before this
i put them on while running
it's very impressive
why do you say so myself
so
dude
yeah the learning curve for dex just
goes
crazy toward the end game
i forgot
it's kind of hoping for a
[Music]
that
what
i didn't even want to do that
i want to hit him a couple times and
then do that
okay
got little nub chicken legs
how
all right
holy [ __ ]
um
[Music]
god that is so cool
let me move
[Music]
i i don't
i dodged it perfectly before
whatever
all right
didn't think it would last that long
it did
this is the big attack right
i tried to dodge and
it like how the [ __ ] do you know where
that's coming from
just the fact that it one shots you bro
like god
either you know the dodger you're [ __ ]
it's crazy i do like i do know how to
dodge
it's just like
pixel perfect with all these guys man
or you're
dead the end game takes a drastic
curve
i guess it depends on your build though
it's like man i don't know this is like
the strongest weapon in the game at
least strongest sword
just kill him yeah
yup
yup
maddie already said that
are you winning son
no i'm getting my [ __ ] pushed in today
which means i'm just getting one shot by
everything like i'll do 85 of every
fight perfectly and then i'll just get
one shot by an attack and it's like okay
i kind of don't like that
i ran out of stamina
are you kidding
i think spire attacks are crazy
oh i almost got stuck
doesn't even do that much damage
[Music]
oh
we might be in trouble here
we're good
[Music]
there you are
still hit me
so
can you dodge that like why is there
like i don't know weird
[Music]
the [ __ ] is that attack
and
didn't leave a trail that time
all right let's get lucky
it's the only it's the only way i died
of this fight is just that
man dude
it just [ __ ] insta kills me every
time
nice two and a half hours of just dying
to bosses
rigged dude i thought my character was
strong and these these bosses don't give
a [ __ ]
pascal was talking to himself for like
10 years
does it matter
why do you care
you could like contribute to the
conversation instead of just pointing
out that pascal is
the only one talking
doesn't matter
[Music]
class do decks
now
[Music]
[Music]
i might be dead
nope
[Music]
[ __ ]
get back here
we have one-on-one time with jake it's
alive
[Music]
and then some view count andy has to
come and ruin it every time no matter
what platform we're on apparently
loser
how do you lose his heads
not sure
but he has five
he tucks three of them in
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
they are cut off i'm just saying he has
five
three of them are cut off
what is this
oh god
no
i got stuck on the
wall
how do we reach a wall in this giant
place
ah godfrey huh nice
where have i not been relaxed dude
the [ __ ] you even talking about
they're definitely snipped off
see that one leaves a trail and i don't
i don't know how to dodge it
very interesting
you gonna disappear nope
yay
[Music]
we did it
yay
man we got way the heck over here
i can't believe we actually hit a wall
in this arena
that gives you 280k
my god
popping it
wow
a what
do we level bigger because we probably
should
yeah that's a lot
maybe we won't get one hit anymore
okay that's nothing
yeah where was i not relaxed
jeez
it's so crazy how people will pop out of
nowhere and just be like you know what
dude
you got a little annoyed with someone in
chat so
maybe you should shut the [ __ ] up
maybe relax and then people would watch
you
it's like every time i open my mouth
and then they just don't say anything
after saying some dumb [ __ ]
like quite literally ever
they just always like go hide
whatever
okay
did we go back to melania
i'm going
i want it
the three more health points will be the
difference
make all the difference
so
it was going so well
kind of
couldn't find a place to heal
holy
have just like tilted people come out of
nowhere
holy [ __ ]
i got a comment on one of my community
posts that said can we not put this
reddit [ __ ] on a pedestal the guy's just
abusing broken fast hitting weapons on a
boss with almost no poise clearly he's
good at the game since he beat melania
but it's really nothing to write home
about or make videos on like how giant
dad
was on the
let me solo her
thing
jesus christ dude can people just calm
down and enjoy something
i don't i don't understand how people
get so like wrapped up in that
or don't
enjoy something you could quite easily
just like not watch it and it's the same
thing
oh my flow's off
brave perry
[Music]
yep
why did my character just swing his
sword over to the right
weird
you're probably right kyle
holy [ __ ] i did it
oh i'm just proud of myself for that
i did the thing i did the thing
oh
have you tried two annual two handing it
yes
but uh i like doing the parries i could
switch more that is true
trying to think of a famous streamer
with any amount of chill i'm coming up
empty oh there's so many of them dude
so many
relax plus streamer equals sleepy
viewers
i don't know about that
hey i dodged the hardest move in the
game up close
oh just just kill me kill me yep
reset
go again
that was not the one
that was not
the one
yeah there's a difference between like
uh
boring streamers and chill streamers
very big difference
unless i'm wrong let me know but i think
so
i could change up my heel pods too
we're finishing it baby
i thought my sword would reach her
i was wrong
she's going crazy
media i press dodge and i'm pretty sure
my character rolled into her foot
no didn't mask didn't didn't max out
anything i'm only at like plus seven
and
like i could put more pots into health
is what i mean
which like because i don't need a i
quite literally don't need any blues
so let's just do this
but listen hey guarantee people are
actually watching this live really think
otherwise oh i i don't
i just sometimes the the hate is so
unwarranted that i just like
i don't know i'm honest i'm just
answering them
i'm not listening to it
because they'll just say like dude relax
and it's like where was i not relaxed
and then they just don't say anything
because they're just
[ __ ] losers who are trying to get a
rise out of a streamer
i promise it does not affect me at all
cool
[Music]
she whipped that one out fast
why would anyone hate watch a stream
uh
they're bored
they
hate their own life
um
they're young
and like
yeah
mix all three together
yep
it's fine man it doesn't bother me
i i will answer them though a lot of
people will just be like
just don't give them any attention it's
like yeah i'll give him a little
attention
i don't care
depressed
eh
i was depressed for a long time and
didn't do [ __ ] like that
i don't think that's an excuse
we got a description kyle
man dude she's whipping those out
[ __ ] fast man
you can just scroll to the description
instead of doing that stuff you know
logan thank you
it's so easy
they need something to do while they
masturbate
maybe
it just doesn't matter
charlie is one of the most relaxed dudes
yep
and he will read hate comments all the
time
this has a 20 000 people in his chat who
will back him up
me not so much
i re i've really been enjoying youtube
like a lot lately like yeah you get some
hate comments like whatever but
compared to twitch it's been a much
better experience
at least for me
i like how people actually talk about
the game on here
it seems like on twitch the only thing
they care about is the streamer
oh
oh trust trust me dude i want the 20k
i want the 20k
for sure
oh i streamed on twitch for four years
pascal it is a completely different
world
with twitch
they
i think there's more of a parasocial
dynamic on on twitch
meaning like
people really connect with the streamer
instead of the content that they're
making does that make sense
youtube audience has been way friendlier
too yeah
hi ray i appreciate that man thank you
it can be a [ __ ] show unless you have a
big like in my opinion if you can have a
big community you can negate a lot of
the [ __ ] show on twitch
now
i mean
there's only like i don't know i never
had my view count on but
obviously it's gonna be a bit different
if we had like 20 000 people in here
god damn it
oh so close
she's really pulling those out fast bro
like way faster than before
twitch for the personalities youtube for
the content
i i think it's yeah absolutely you're
right but i think it's sort of i think
it's unhealthy on twitch
i really do
like the
the the fact that i still get messages
from people asking like
that i can please go stream rocket
league on twitch is insane
and if i don't do that they just like
don't think i exist
brave
not our best start
probably the worst start we could have
had
i have um spent a lot less time on
twitch recently
i've like you know just because i've
made a full switch to youtube for
streaming and content
like videos and you know obviously but
um
yeah i i don't i don't go on twitch very
much
either
lately
and it's been
i'm not gonna lie it's been kind of nice
okay
oh we're working on it adrian
this weapon does that
[Music]
there it is
probably waterfowl
yep
[Music]
i tried to parry
how am i alive
i don't know
we could get her armor set and look at
it a bit deeper
tried to parry again when i wasn't
facing the right direction
and
then i i just [ __ ] up man
that was going so good
and i just made too many mistakes
i would imagine it would be the hollow
tree
who who are the demigods that actually
even give a [ __ ] about the golden order
yeah
radon technically and more got
oh i've beaten this game like six times
adrian
i'm trying to do it with this build and
that's kind of tough
i beat the whole game with the rivers of
blood that that weapon is [ __ ] insane
she will no defeat
i think radon is loves the golden order
he's just insane
what
hold on
oh yeah we beat reichard like 10 hours
ago on this playthrough
god that combo is nutty
[Music]
kyle i already beat the game with the
blasphemous point
i don't want to do it again
has she done waterfall yet no definitely
not i'm doing this
he looked up to
godfrey
probably should not have been reading
chat there
because i needed to dodge in
i stopped
not her best
not her worst
a lot of hits
it's mr perry
do you think the serpent that devoured
reichardt is an outer god
i don't i do not think
that it's an outer god
it is just a
its own being
that devours gods
do we know godfrey's dad
do you mean radon's dad radon's dad is
ratagon
and his mother is rinala
my god
[Music]
his armorer idolizes godfrey though i'm
sure he liked ratagon too his dad
i don't know though
man my parries suck right now
i i think i think in dlc we're going
into space
you know what's going to happen is we're
going to touch mikkel's hand in that egg
and we're gonna get transported
somewhere
says the serpent will devour the world
only an outer god can do that i mean we
don't know that
oh did my game crash i think it did
hello
oh my god it crashed that's so rare
at least i think it did yep
dead
yeah we don't know that for sure
i love this game
oh what is the beast champion's weapon
sir
same kyle same
maybe it is an outer god i just don't
know all i'm saying is like
i don't know
oh about devouring the world does it say
it's a god though
oh yeah my for as big of a game as this
is my game has not crashed uh too many
times
i've had rocket league crash more than
this [ __ ] game
i did five of my placement matches in
rocky league kyle
or everybody else too i guess
i got bored
uninstalled
so
wow all right i hit the dodge button and
nothing happened
it looks like the hollow tree
what if it's the great tree
because we know that the great trees
stood before the earth tree
and the er tree took over
the great tree
which could be the hollow tree
what a start
[Music]
shouldn't have said anything
cool
just
do
so [ __ ] good
to just dying
everyone's still learning
even vati video said that in his um
in his lore video today
he even mentioned like
that we're all still learning we're all
gonna make he he did like the last five
minutes of his video today was him
correcting himself from his original
video
so
we're all still learning that's what's
so fun about it
to me
and honestly we're never
gonna completely know everything
it wasn't dark souls and
this game is definitely the same
really like this attack huh
brave
and even that flow chart was wrong
for some stuff not a lot though
now that sucks
[ __ ]
thank you fate
humble person
uh it seems i find an amazing
characteristic
not many humble people in the world
i mean yeah you got to take your you
know if you got it wrong
that that's one thing i've i've learned
in life
if you if you get something wrong you
don't have to double down
you can admit to being wrong
and people will forgive
depends on what that is
[Music]
knew it
not great
not terrible
why am i getting hit by that
hey
i know you want to do it that's why you
backed up
she's scared of me
imagine
there you are
okay she hit a wall
that sucks
[Music]
what
pain
what oh yeah she gets health back
imagine forgetting that
oh i hit her toe
oh my god that scared the [ __ ] out of me
oh my god
i hit her toe dude
oh man i gotta chill for a second that
was not going well
that was awesome dude
okay go
[Music]
[Music]
uh
i tried to parry
i'm scared
does she ever sit still
she kept jumping in the sky man
man
we barely
man
we gotta learn phase two don't we we're
getting phase one down
uh about half the time
now
i can't figure out how to stagger her
there
mad aggressive
calm yourself val witch
i'm dead
that was such a close
grab
i'm telling like every attack she has in
the book she can just pull out of
nowhere she's like yeah i don't really
care
how close or you know like any usually
you can bait out attacks from distance
right
not not not with melania
i guess that hit me
do we just ignore parrying chat and just
dodge and hit
let's go
i think we do though because that was
insane damage i don't even think the
parries are worth
we never stagger her
like barely ever
let's try it
i'm gonna keep it on my back for the
option but
we'll see we'll see
uh
that's not good
that hurt a lot
i didn't even know what her second half
of her attack does there because i
always parry it
[Music]
[Music]
i just duck her
i'm the best
we'll take it
god that attack was [ __ ] fast
i might just yoink out my shield on that
attack
and parry
when i see your step to the left i'm
just gonna yank out the shield
and just
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna get good
i'm gonna get good in my own way
all right i think we have the rundown of
how we do this let's do it we just gotta
do it now
i didn't do it i got scared that's a
that's a quick input dude
all right i got staggered and i died
and this this this [ __ ] fight man is
quite literally insane
why literally
insane i just want to beat her so i can
look at the boss room bro
that's that's all i want to do
that's it
still hits you there unfortunately
okay
i didn't die
i barely have enough health to survive
that
let's go
mimic does make everything easier
i don't want to use mimic in this
playthrough though
oh we might get a bleed there
we
go free jelly
let's do this buddy
[ __ ] her up
[Music]
what
she was facing a completely different
direction and then just decided to hit
me
[Music]
don't go after me
it didn't know what to go for
no she's getting health dude
i should not have used the summon
[Music]
not worth it all
dude bro god dang it
she is so
fast in stage two
there's additions to everything bro okay
so any type of summon here is just not
gonna do it
i'm not using mimic
[Music]
definitely time she would use it right
yep
thought i had an l2
didn't have stamina
ugh
up
we're really close to a wall
nice
[Music]
bish
come on boys
are you not dead what
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
no that's waterfowl
oh i forgot she can even do that in this
phase man
i forgot she can even do waterfowl in
second phase
this boss is quite literally crazy
what is the start
okay
her sequences there were so weird
man
we do so much more damage to handing but
the
just having the ability to parry makes
me comfortable
[Music]
[Music]
so
thought my sword would hit her there
it's just so unlucky that she wanted to
use that right in that moment that i
wanted to heal
rng
could you bait her into an attack and
use l2 to punish
i mean
i feel like i'm doing that a lot already
[Music]
[Music]
okay
yeah i feel like i'm doing that
a lot
already
i mean what's the percentage that i just
died of that attack at pretty much every
[ __ ] time
90 of the of my deaths are just a
waterfowl
i feel
a regression
coming on
okay
i dropped my phone
feels so much more comfortable with the
parry man
it's gonna go back
the fight
the fight is so good without waterfowl
it's such a beautiful fight
until waterfowl
yeah we're getting better at dodging it
but i mean if i'm too close sometimes
it's just like well guess we're dead
not even using perry now
like i feel like that was a very quick
use of it right
like that came out of quite literally
nowhere just i'm hitting her and then
all of a sudden jumps in the air
i'm using it i'm already in a she's
using it i'm already in an animation i'm
dead
i i don't think that's good game design
i just don't
everything else about this fight is
beautiful except that attack man
okay
i'm starting to get mad
yeah
as soon as i saw it i was full sprint
running away and i still got caught from
it
i'm
i'm gonna stand by
i'm gonna stand by it that that attack
needs to be changed it really does
i think it r it literally is the only
thing i'm thinking about the entire
fight
which is not how a fight should be
i'm not nervous it's just
i feel like i'm getting [ __ ] over by
one attack constantly it's frustrating
even in stage two
[Music]
there you go
literally doing the fight perfectly
until all of a sudden boop
she wants to use it and i'm dead unless
i get lucky rolling underneath her
i don't think that's good
i really don't
the repetitive deaths and such i don't
mind dying
it's the way that i'm dying
that i think is [ __ ]
these games are all about dying
in repetition
but there is no other fight in the game
where i'm only thinking of one attack
that the boss does
none
it's the only way i die like it's so
dumb
that's like five times in a row that
exact same way
where i'm just like in the flow of the
fight and the fight is ruined by this
attack
it's frustrating how often i die from
just that attack
i don't mind the dying like i said it's
just this
well if you think about it
getting through these challenging boss
fights
you need the repetition you need the you
need the reps
to get some uh success out of it so i
don't want to leave the fight you know
what i mean
like i could go cool off but i'll just
come back and restart the process all
over again of just trying to avoid the
waterfall dance
there it is
so
[Music]
see what i mean
i don't know
i'm trying to like the fight so much
because when i made that tearless video
everyone was saying like dude melania's
the best fight ever and i'm and my
opinion of it was pretty low
where because of this one attack and
so i even i even said in that video i
was like or in the comments i said
okay i'm gonna go at it again i'm gonna
try and do it with a different build and
see if i like it and
i mean i've beaten her like five six
times
all with different builds and this is
always
the the time that i have with it it
takes me hours to beat her and i die to
the waterfall
no matter what build i have
so i'm
standing by it i think it's bad game
design the waterfowl is just bad
i don't want to run away from the boss
when i'm in a good flow state with it
you know
i want to fight
man that was a stagger too
[Music]
oh
oh god the tree sentinel
god the draconic tree sentinel
that [ __ ] lightning attack
let me solo her died over 200 times with
this boss to completely figure it out
and even then it's a 10 minute fight of
mostly running away
and just waiting for more
or the opportunity
the header
there it is and i'm dead
the one in the floating temple uh well
that's one of them but the one outside
of the
uh capital city
is the first time you meet a draconic
tree sentinel
and i found that
lightning attack to just be the bane of
my existence for three hours
[Music]
god damn it
no
i don't
i don't think i should need it because i
mean
i haven't
there's many moments where i just run
away and dodge it and we're fine i don't
think the quick step would make uh
that big of a difference
i shouldn't need it
we were seeing more success with the two
hand
and then of course she does the move i
like immediately after i put it away
dude
i mean this is quite literally like 10
times in a row with that happening
have to run away when i see her health
that low i have to
which sucks
ass
so
[Music]
no this is how the fight was before the
update
okay her health is at that stage for
sure
right
i i feel like if i go in there it is
okay
i wanted to go in and hit her just to
get her to do it
good thing i had that bubble
oh
ugly fight
come on
yeah i think that's where the rng came
in for you ray
she didn't do the waterfowl as much so
you got the dub
which i think is how this fight goes
which is not
good
game design
you can bleed her out of the air but
that's
very
not consistent obviously
because you have to
guess the invisible invisible bleed
truck
i'm just talking about waterfowl
and not every
move can be interrupted
oh i shouldn't have done that
maybe that's the move i mean it's
impossible to do consistently
you can't just like judge the
the bleed
when she's in the air
but
definitely not every move can be
interrupted by doing one thing
consistently it you have to get lucky
with bleed
or frost spider whatever it is like
whatever build you're using you have to
get lucky with a proc
which is not something that you can do
consistently that's what i mean
i mean i could do what
let me solo her does and this is this
until she does one attack in particular
and then punish
[Music]
it's not very fun though
or i can [ __ ] up once and die
where are you like getting any of this
ray
she kills me in two hits with like 43
vigor
it's not a lot of weakness to her
you got this
adrian thank you
for the five dollar super chat
oh no
okay we're fine
thank you thank you thank you
i mean we're we are gonna get it
it's gonna happen
it's i'm just
i don't like this
fight i don't
well i shouldn't say that
i don't like one attack
knew it
why did that hit me
um
that grab was [ __ ]
fast dude
just like so many attacks
just
have no flow to it it's just like a it's
like a trigger
like they just bop
out of nowhere
and kill you
[Music]
you can definitely waterfowl here
come on
so
hey
so
no
leave me alone oh my god
she got so aggressive
just non-stop
[ __ ]
you guys ever um maybe this is just me
but
even like i know i have stamina there
and i'm holding
a sprint
or circle or b whatever controller
you're using and backwards right but
your character is facing forward
sometimes it takes a [ __ ]
hour for my character to start running
the direction that i'm holding the stick
in
that very well could be me
it's like i know i have stamina though
it just doesn't
not a good start
[Music]
what
i tried to attack
it was bad
we're alive
somehow
i need to not do that
after the waterfall
man bro
hmm
you're good ray
i think people just want to see me
[ __ ] finally do this thing dude
i think this is def like this build is
the heart this is definitely the hardest
way i've fought melania
a hundred percent
why did why did my character swing
a second time i did not press
a button
i must have
[Music]
uh
um
we have some regression tries but
it's definitely better than before
why are okay
that's great mel gibson
if i'm gonna watch you this long
i expect you to pull it off
i'm trying man i swear
i didn't think it would be this [ __ ]
hard
definitely yeah yeah
[Music]
i figured out why she catches me there
sometimes i'm running uphill
oh no
that is just
straight up unlucky
i was just in the flow of it man and i
just went at it and
instant
win if she uses it
all right i'm this confident chat
i'm this confident in this particular
try
for no reason
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know why
i do that
sometimes
that was kind of awesome
is she not being like way more hyper
aggressive
this round than
ever before
[Music]
yo it's bones
what's up bro
there it is
thanks for becoming a member man
how you been good to see you
[Music]
come on
i might go back to the parries man
i'm not finding my my strut
my step
it's coming soon i know it
just gonna ruin this attempt i'm going
for it
okay
three health
two health
[Music]
oh
man
she
instantly used the waterfowl
instant waterfowl
in stage two right away
i hit her one time waterfowl dead
[ __ ]
busy as hell
those things here you're looking good
you've seen your tweets everything's
been great man same here though busy as
balls
it's good busy though
hopefully all is well
used it as an opener
that is quite literally insane
apparently i like saying that
i'll take it
she might use it here though
i killed plastics
plastiducci
there you are and i'm too close to a
wall
i literally got stuck on
that branch right there
yeah thank you for the membership bones
i appreciate that you're like my fourth
member or something
yeah i killed plastics in like i don't
know six tries maybe less five and then
we've been on melania for about four
hours of the stream about three
three and a half hours
a grab
to open
okay
i thought her being in the air on a
jumping
attack
you know i had to go top tier
oh what's a legend bro wait a minute i
don't even
i don't even remember
they don't change the colors
wait
i made that like 50 bucks right holy
[ __ ] thank you man
i don't even remember
i haven't been streaming that much i've
just been focusing on making videos i do
want to
uh
i do want to stream more
i gotta get in the flow
kind of like with this fight but thank
you so much man
i [ __ ] forgot that there were tears
i saw the legend and i'm like wait a
minute that's different that's like
that's like a big one
thank you man holy [ __ ] that is really
nice of you
i said that
um
[Music]
oh yeah
i'm liking the openers
with the uh heavy attacks
she could use waterfowl
i would love it if you just used it so
that we can get it out of the way
thank
you running uphill
all right a little unlucky we ran into
the wall but it is what it is
she's being hyper
i don't know why chat
i don't know why
i'm feeling it on this one
this one
just feels right
[Music]
you just saw that
that just happened
i may have had one health
this has to be the one
it's not it's not the one
i mean i'm using a very heavy bleed
weapon
so
i'm also using bleed
should i apply a bleed to my weapon
i think that would make a big diff
i got blood grease i got five and i have
frostbite
i'm going all out baby let's go
let's do it get rid of that [ __ ]
let's go baby
it's it's time to get this [ __ ] done
remove jelly not using jelly
it's time to do this i'm tired of it
you're tired of it we're all tired of it
let's get it done let's go
this is it
i am quite
over it
how is she one shotting you like that
because she grabbed my ass
and split it open
and then killed me
does it hurt
this is morgot's armor yeah
[Music]
didn't like that
i didn't like any of that
that was all not fun
[Music]
i'm gonna stab that ass
stab that ass
run
[ __ ] man
i'm gonna apply
frost
on stage two
i shouldn't have said anything because
now we're worried about getting there
now
come on jake
why was that just stretching
like sometimes she'll just do that right
in front of her when i'm that far away
and other times she'll just
bum rush me bruh
man
all right
it did help though
look like she did not move as far as
whatever
[Music]
man
bro this this fight is ridiculous
ridiculous
man
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
i have not struggled this much on her
in any other build i've had
oh my god
oh my god
bruh
i had one health
so
[Music]
no
i tried to do it twice man
because like she just yanks it out of
the
yanks it out of her ass
whenever she feels like it
awesome
i don't feel like the bleeds doing that
much
[ __ ] man
this isn't on new game plus or anything
this is just straight up
level 114
like seriously
realize i was this high of a level
[Music]
the regression's
settling in
like what [ __ ] level do you have to
be to beat her
and not a hundred tries
thank you flesh
i mean i've i've beaten her
six times
just the this particular build has just
made it feel impossible
i've never had to think about my level
when i fight her
this [ __ ] deck strength build is
garbage against her
this is just the weapon i chose to do
for this play through that's it
i normally base a build off of a weapon
and then try to beat the game with it
i'm gonna ask something has she water
fouled once
in this in this run
i don't remember her doing it in that
run i i might have just forgot
[Music]
so
[Music]
no
how how how
[Music]
so
hey
[Music]
flesh
bro what a [ __ ] run though huh oh my
god
what a run though
that was like
a [ __ ] movie
where
the hero dies at the end
holy
i should have applied a bleed i just had
no
[Music]
i had no heals toward the end man
it's like
yup
close we're very close
might not be this one
considering the start
i tried to roll
oh oh oh oh oh oh
okay
that slice from her foot killed me
we could tell that was not the one
my uh my patience levels are really
being tested today and i'm quite proud
of myself
gotten a little frustrated but not
tilted off the face of the earth
[Music]
can you stop swinging your sword ma'am
like
we never stopped there holy [ __ ]
and see why radon wanted to kill you
not that time
i'm melania blade of micklov if i choose
waterfowl it's a 98 chance to kill a
[ __ ] player no matter how much health
they have
yep why did we let her put the arm on
i want to know
this ain't some anime [ __ ]
i would have rushed her down
before she could have put it on
all right
i'm getting too silly
that that last good run roll really took
a lot out of me there man like i was
dodging quite literally everything with
no health and and no uh
yeah no health
and then
it all ended on me getting too close and
her using waterfowl of course
that's i took a lot out of me bro it
really did
that hurt my soul
i wish we could do bets
on youtube
like channel point bets
that'd be fun
um what
was that
[Music]
that one that run really was good
it was kinda nuts
i have no pull on youtube
kidding me
i'm new
dang it
it sucks that if you run uphill she can
catch you
even if you get off to a good run
i think uh youtube lives will be um like
i feel like
pretty soon they're gonna start
releasing some cool stuff
i don't know
i think ludwig and tim the tatman have
been you know in the scene for a while
it's like time to make a move you know
should kick my head
[Music]
no
uh-oh
she gets up so fast dude
no idea how that hit me
yeah if you're too close nicholas you
get hit
you die
you don't just get hit you die
i've gotten lucky a couple times
they've been bringing some players in
like you said lugwood and those guys
they have
i believe in it man i wouldn't be here
if i didn't you know
okay
really good chat really good
i'm thinking freeze
that seemed really close
[Music]
i ran out of stamina i think my my
character just didn't [ __ ] roll
or he got staggered i think he got
staggered bro
yeah i mean i'm i'm making this
i'm making this
this fight about as hard as i can i'm
pretty sure i'm under leveled
i don't know
if you guys think that i'm 1
14 i think that's under leveled for her
i really do
um
with probably the hardest build to beat
her with
and i don't want to use summons
so
it's not a rune level one run but it's
hard
[Music]
give me the bleed dude
i just wanted to bleed
[Music]
she could do it
there it is
i would have died if i didn't have that
thing
the wonders physics
that's crazy
[Music]
i mean i would say this area is harder
than the end game
wouldn't you
it's technically a secret area
this is definitely the hardest fight in
the game hardest area in the game
way harder than ratagon and eldenbees
no i [ __ ] up i dodged backwards
that's my fault
yeah this is way harder than um you know
like at like the ashen capital city
way harder than rat
ratagon godfrey
yeah
way harder bro
i would say like
um you'd be like 120
for end game and then this is like
beyond the end game this is like 150
territory
to have like a pretty not a
like a balance go at it
you know what i mean
yeah i'll go [ __ ] myself
it's real quick
maybe i'll go [ __ ] myself and then get
my head on my ass and i can beat this
chick
[Music]
or we could just not be dumb and go beat
moog
because at this point like i'm not i'm
gonna just [ __ ] go to bed if i stop
streaming so
i want to work out before bed i've been
in a good routine
no i don't smoke
no no
melania's gonna make me take it up
though
oh god
well
not lost or i was i didn't i honestly
didn't expect her to do that so early
running a new
level 80 character went to get a
talisman from concentrated snow fields
thought about doing her and then went
nope yeah that's a good idea
that's a good idea
i don't know how you beat this game
without a smoker too
i am just generally a very calm person
very patient
i still get frustrated obviously but i'm
not you know i'm [ __ ] human
i don't like losing
[Music]
that attack was so ridiculously fast
i tried
bro that would be the greatest clip of
all time if you could somehow parry that
attack that would change everything we
put that on tick tock get 20 million
views
just
[Music]
parry that [ __ ] attack bro oh my god
we're still here ray why did i enter the
room so weird did you see that what the
[ __ ]
i'm hungry too
i also think she's broken i think that
one attack is broken but i've said that
enough
i think we know my thoughts on this boss
fight
it's [ __ ] broken
so
i tried to yoink out my shield in perry
i went for it
i don't regret it
but i [ __ ] up
i [ __ ] up
no i
was i out of stamina their chat because
i hit the roll and it didn't do anything
[ __ ]
i heard procs kill bosses in second
phase now insta kill due to update
so you're telling me if i got my freeze
off
it would have killed her instantly
or my bleed
[ __ ] that would have been nice
i get buried i don't think so
she did that attack
no
i just tried to strafer it didn't work
well we'll find out
if i can do it
i can't even get the stage too right now
do your waterfowl dance oh my god it's
so pretty oh my god totally not broken
[ __ ] four
i my character decided did you see what
he did
he like slid instead of just went the
other way like he does all the time
i
saw the signs
i opened up my eyes i saw the signs i'm
gonna do this or somehow close even
though it looks like i'm trash
i'm losing my [ __ ] mind
could just go kill mode get three levels
make this way easier but i'm just gonna
make this hard on myself [ __ ] it dude
i love pain and suffering i played
rocket league for six years dude you
think i don't know pain and suffering
millennia you think i don't know pain
and suffering
it's all i know
yeah i'm playing fantastic and i'm dying
to one attack
one
pretty much i didn't die to it that time
but
95 percent of the time i'm dead to
waterfowl
i feel like i'm playing great too
i just die so quick
watch this be the difference
i'm gonna put a [ __ ] helmet on
watch this make all the defensive
difference we could ever have needed
yep i played pro rocket league i have 74
like airway 7 400 hours on that [ __ ]
game
um i was ssl for
well i was top hundred for five years
she can do it
my advice to you is to stop playing
rocket league
best decision i ever made
there's people out there ray who or
callum who have beaten this boss at
level one
nope
i did some dumb [ __ ] there
i met your soul in here
yeah
yeah
i mean it's like a
this is like a [ __ ]
mission for me now
nope
they did not use cheat engine
well
i stopped playing rocket league because
it has the worst community in gaming a
hundred percent
they just use exploits to beat them at
level one like constant pairing
the fight's like 20 minutes long
because they have to wait for certain
attacks
oh no
the helmet isn't helping
dude i can't even get the stage 2
anymore i don't know what's going on
is
uh streaming alden ring
squilla killa i think that's who you're
talking about
very toxic community
yeah
yeah don't uh i don't like the rocky
league community
i don't like the people that play the
game i don't like the content creators i
don't like anything about it the only
good thing about rocket league is the
pro scene
and even that is uh
pretty much run by 16 year olds
who think they're like gods on earth
i promise you rocket league is way more
toxic than league of legends i promise
you just haven't made it there yet
there to the to the ranks that'll show
you that i suppose
she's got a waterfowl soon
that's sue
this could not be a better start
there you are poor
no idea why i even got hit
that attack after is so nuts
oh i know league of legends is bad
i promise
rocket league is worse
i promise
it runs deep too
deep in the community
come here
freezer bleed freezer bleed
freeze
all right this better killer if i
procker bro
[Music]
i died
she just went nuts there bro
he just went
quite ape [ __ ]
nonstop h ape shittery
to kill me there
and she
did
i'm just happy to see stage two
i'm pretty much consistently hit by one
of those phantoms
it's the one that comes in hot
like the fourth one
where you have to roll
the previous one
and that one comes in
at the end of the animation of your roll
if that makes sense
so did i not hit you or uh what's up
i'm i have consistently staggered her
every time when she tries to do an
attack and that was a bloodhound's
finesse
l2
that did not stagger her
incredible
this fight might be impossible at this
level like
without using the exploits of of the
level one rune [ __ ]
this this might be impossible
i'm going back to pairing i mix i'm
mixing it up
there's got to be more attacks that i
can parry right
yeah there we are
i think when she does the backhand i can
as well i think most attacks i can parry
i just like yeah i only know
the timing of one
and it's very hard
i just want to do this so bad
okay i won't parry i won't perry i won't
perry
i that attack sometimes randomly
staggers you for no [ __ ] reason
can happen
we gotta run
she's gonna do it in three
two
one
you think i i know what i'm doing
[ __ ]
either i kill her right here or she does
the waterfowl
or she does that
fair
[ __ ] chill
i know your health is low
she just did that attack four [ __ ]
times
four
like suck my ass
wait to start
[Music]
no clue how any of that is [ __ ]
hitting me
oh
i i healed
and the
the [ __ ] input [ __ ]
the input of me healing
makes her do the only attack that i
can't [ __ ] dodge in that moment after
i'm done healing because i have to go
through the [ __ ] animation
such [ __ ]
that one frustrated me damn oh my god
[ __ ] input [ __ ]
hey let's put in the game where as soon
as the player heals just [ __ ] make
them do some dumbass attack that they
can't dodge
there it is just happened again
cut i guess you can't stagger when she
does a grab anymore
who's spamming
nobody
i
saw
the signs i wonder if we can get to 6
000 subscribers by tomorrow morning
that'd be cool
how many of you guys are not subscribed
let me know
don't lie
i had to remind you didn't i
no
i've been fighting this boss
for four hours
not forever
do you know how long forever is it's a
long time
[Music]
you want me to check for you
am i your mom
i hate it here
i like you cut g
okay
i am going hollow sperm just like your
sperm
just like your [ __ ]
hollow and empty
yeah now i'm getting weird
maybe i'd dedicate an entire stream
tomorrow to beating melania
it'll be five minutes long
i'll title it if i beat melania the
video ends
your mom's in a very negative mindset
[Music]
ow
i am melania blade of mikla
and nobody likes me
how do you pronounce the first part of
that right there elf heel
that's not cool i don't appreciate that
i'm sorry man she's not in a good mood
because she's waiting in my bed right
now
i'm in a negative mindset so she's in a
negative mindset because i just won't
hop in bed
just makes sense
you should
you should get more tears so you can use
less healing
[Music]
so
i don't think i had stamina
okay
sometimes she doesn't do that
that time she did
yeah i think i accidentally crouched
now we're making mechanical mistakes
not good
yeah it's probably a good idea dark
souls
but
i want to do it
like this
it's like for my honor at this point
no i'm not gonna apologize i'm just
stating facts
come here
i freaked
i'll take it i'll take it i'll take it
oh
input
no
hey it staggered her that time
no
dude
okay ray
i
don't
[ __ ] care
like my song
i'm losing my mind
and that's when we're gonna do it right
guys
when i lose my [ __ ]
i'm going
i went at it
could not be a worse start
keep it going
listen if you guys think anything i say
alright i have said in the last probably
35 minutes is serious
need to calm down
that seemed a bit early didn't it
but okay
she's still going
keep going
why'd you
stop just keep going
just keep going man
dude for real i cannot imagine the stds
you would get having sex with melania
well i know exactly the std you would
get
scarlet rot
your dick would fall off
you guys do know that your mom joke
right
i hope so
oh
we got lucky with the bleed brock
we'll take the luck
can't get lucky twice
oh my god
are we that attracted to melania
are we really
are you too much of a [ __ ] to use
bloodhound's fang ash of war second
attack
shut up
now
guys i am starting to believe that this
is not going to happen today
i'm it's it's seeking into me
i mean you guys are getting legitimately
uh offended by your mom joke
that's not a good sign
i don't hate melania
she can't even [ __ ] see
she could just be trying to swat a fly
out of the air
three bucks
but
a rage boner
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
that's
she's like learning she doesn't get
staggered
probably time to level up
[Music]
answer me this though chat
if i left fought moog leveled up came
back
would you respect the killing of melania
less
i bet you would
oh i know callum i don't think they're
serious but i mean ray like actually
left so
that's the sub price
there's multiple
i only know the american dollar
what is this gyro
i call it [ __ ]
guys it's out of principle
i would respect it less
is your honor worth that much
it's everything
could i really call myself the elden
lord if i went and leveled
maybe maybe i could
it's better than watching your cheeks
get clap for hours okay maybe you guys
are different because twitch would be
like no stay here forever and die
constantly
okay i'll leave
hey man i'm out
i'm out that's all i needed was for you
guys to be like nah
i need to look into that [ __ ] town
more
you guys ever do that
you just see things in the game and you
just hit it
and then run away
i do that all the time
i'll go out of my way to do it
you can't respect yourself that much you
played rocky league for six years
that's [ __ ] facts
good point
but now i respect myself
more
that's a bear
whoa
i'm gonna die
oh oh oh oh we're swinging wildly i see
okay okay
hey a bear's coming dog
there's quite literally a bear behind
you bro
all right hey um i guess everything just
wants to end my day today holy [ __ ]
okay
i i ca i can't win today holy [ __ ]
oh my god
oh my god
have you ever seen that npc so
aggressive
what is happening is my game broken
this build sucks
i'm i'm confirming it a deck strength
build late in game is terrible
terrible everything counters it
everything
when you stream it next jake
i don't know
whenever i guess
i don't know i don't have a schedule
for streaming
i've been focused on the videos
i [ __ ] hate it here
i swear it's because i'm streaming like
everything's going wrong just because
i'm live right now
mykolo lore would be cool
i haven't seen a ton on that
i got [ __ ] debated bro i tried to go
around
have a good one column
i'm just gonna go right to moog you can
get to mode pretty fast
through the telly
hardest boss gravity
that guy gets to live
that's a good idea though frederick
i don't know much of anything about
saint trina
oh
still
all the way out here huh
catch them lacking chat
catch them lacking
oh [ __ ]
okay
yeah i was gonna do that didn't quite
work out that way
what the [ __ ] are these things this do
any of you know
oh god
goodbye
okay
dude moak's not [ __ ] easy either
i think we do these tomorrow
i really do
or another day
because i kind of want to work on a
video tomorrow
they're froggos
i think that's how you pronounce it
albanatrix they look very different from
the all all been
from those
that we usually see
like the skinny dudes
they look super different and i'm pretty
sure those are
the alveonattrics
you see bits of it around the main map
how do we teleport there what is the
purpose
i'm pretty sure uh
pretty sure melania sends us there or
not melania melana
sends us there
because
we need to release the rune of death
because
i think
this is a theory i made a whole video on
it you can go watch it
that melano
is the glomide queen
and would want us to go fight malakath
to release the rune of death
so
yeah
all that
chat
oh this is the rune farming spot right
here
oh
[Music]
so what you just hit him with this
like for real
how do i aim
[ __ ]
oh
what
i have [ __ ]
how is it not working
oh it's the bow
what
they fix this
nope
um
you guys really do that
oh my god
i just realized we have this
oh my god
do i respec
20 arcane
we'll take off some decks put it in
arcane
gg
melania dies
thoughts
maybe we do it tomorrow
boys
i'm out of here
i'm not saying hi i'm saying bye
don't do that
all right all right all right the end
game is breaking me here but i
appreciate you all being here for a
great stream
i'm sorry
i couldn't do it
it hurts my soul i really thought i
could but this build is [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
against melania
but maybe we can get it done tomorrow
i appreciate all the support
thank you all the new to all the new
members today and all the new subs
and
super chat today
from adrian thank you
so
i don't know when i'll be on again
because i don't have a schedule for
streaming
i try to make three videos a week that's
kind of my like internal schedule that
i'm never gonna announce because i hate
schedules
but just make sure to subscribe turn on
the notification bell so that you don't
miss anything
follow me on twitter
please i my twitter has been so dog [ __ ]
for the past two years and all of my
followers are rocket league people
and it sucks okay
so
go to the description
do that i'd appreciate it thank you guys
have a fantastic rest of your night
i think i will be back soon because
streaming's fun
i kind of missed it so have a great
night thank you all goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye